miles de personas se manifestaron en
Madrid este sábado contra el gobierno de
Pedro Sánchez bajo el lema por España la
democracia y la Constitución varios
miembros de los partidos de derecha el
PP y ciudadanos y del partido de extrema
derecha vox que fue convocada por varias
asociaciones conservadoras
los manifestantes acusan a Pedro Sánchez
de ser un traidor y de pisotear la
Constitución una crítica que hace
referencia entre otras cosas a la
supresión del delito de sedición
aprobada en diciembre por el senado Pues
básicamente por el eslogan que figura
allí en el estrado por España por la
democracia por la Constitución para
defender la actual España la que nos
permite vivir en libertad que es la
España de que nace con la constitución
del 78 quiero decir que que nos ha
permitido vivir bastantes años de
democracia y yo Considero que hay que
defenderla porque ahora mismo puede
estar en peligro los que se movilizaron
también denuncian la situación económica
del país y las reformas de Sánchez
entonces creo que era necesario venir y
decir que Basta ya y que lo importante
es que salgamos de esta crisis económica
que tenemos tan importante y que no se
gaste el dinero en cosas tan superfluas
y que tampoco nos importan a los
españoles en Pedro Sánchez afirmó que
los que se manifestaron son nostálgicos
y quieren una España uniforme y por
tanto exclu